[Musique]
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous alain
frachon bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur ce
plateau mère suffit d'être la plume bien
connu du quotidien le monde où vous
tenez la chronique internationale on
vous lit chaque jeudi dans le quotidien
du soir sur l'état du monde un autre
monde l'ère des dictateurs c'est le nom
du livre que vous publiez chez perrin et
qui rassemble une centaine de ses
chroniques écrites depuis
2014 chronique politique la chronique de
politique étrangère est un exercice
moins dangereux que la guerre
écrivez-vous alain frachon reste que la
compréhension du monde et son décryptage
a fortiori sont un exercice compliqué la
guerre en ukraine en est une
illustration comprendre l'aventurisme
poutinien écrivez vous êtes une gageur
oui il n'avait aucun intérêt à lancer
cette guerre il avait installé son
pouvoir il avait acquis une présence
incontournable au moyen-orient il
discutait avec l'europe il discutait
avec les états unis il avait rencontré
le président buydens en juin s'il n'ya
pas très longtemps à genève ils étaient
sortis satisfaits de cette conversation
les deux pays américains et russes
avaient décidé de lancer deux deux
conversations de négociation de type de
négociation une sur le cyberespace et
l'autre sur la sécurité en europe et il
y avait plusieurs forums disponible pour
discuter de la sécurité en europe et
puis soudain en décembre poutine pose un
ultimatum
absolument inacceptable dans la forme
est d'autant plus est dans le fond aussi
d'ailleurs est d'autant plus
inacceptable qu'il y avait en principe
deux canaux de négociations et qu'il y à
une organisation où les russes sont
l'organisation dans la sécurité et la
coopération en europe où l'on discute de
ces questions là et donc curieusement il
commet une bourde stratégique de
proportions historiques et qui nous
rappelle celle que commis aussi le
président bush en allant attaquer l'irak
en 2003 avec le prix qui est celui qu'il
connaît que les états unis connaissent
aujourd'hui on va y revenir sur le plus
court terme dans sur la situation sur le
terrain en ukraine comment est ce que
vous comprenez ces efforts concentrés
russe sur le dombass n'exclut rien sur
les sur les futurs semaine voilà alors
bon c'est souvent comme ça dans la
guerre vous n'avez pas intérêt à définir
clairement vos objectifs vous avez
intérêt à rester vague et c'est ce qu'il
a fait au début il a sans doute pensé
que kiev tomberait très rapidement qu'il
mettrait un gouvernement à la botte de
la russie et que les autres villes aussi
se soumettrait à l'armée responsable
s'est pas du tout passé comme ça parce
qu'il vit dans une bulle qui n'a rien à
voir avec la réalité il s'est construit
une sorte de fantasme ils imaginaient
que les russes allaient être accueillis
avec des fleurs il n'a pas pris la
mesure de ce qu'était la force du
patriotisme ou du nationalisme ukrainien
et donc il commet cette bourde géante
alors qu'est ce qui fait à ce moment-là
il laisse entendre mais c'est pas très
clair non plus qu il se rabat sur l'est
sur toute cette bande est de l'ukraine
frontalière de la russie à l'ukraine
c'est un pays un peu plus grand que la
france c'est pas rien il se rabat sur
cette bande frontalière où il a déjà
depuis 2014 favoriser l'émergence de
mouvements sécessionnistes
ukrainien mais pro russe il favorise
l'émergence et dont il a déclaré les
républiques autonomes que personne ne
reconnaît à part la russie et la
biélorussie alors il semble que c'est ce
qu'il souhaite alors il gouvernera sur
un amas de ruines un tas de ruines mario
paul c'est une ville de près de cinq
cent mille habitants elle est à 90% des
truites la ville remarquable reportage
que vous venez de passer absolument
remarquable sur le front sur la ligne de
front près de cette ville dont je ne
prononcerai pas non plus prononçable
mais remarquable reportage il semble
bien que le sort de cette ville soit
celui de marioupol aussi détruit à 90%
contrôler le donbass et après voilà
après justement parce que vous dites et
on salue au passage effectivement
johnatan watch et amaral à mehdaoui qui
signe ce reportage dans le donbass vous
écrivez que vos quarante ans de
journalisme vous ont appris une chose
que les hommes forts les autocrates
pensent ce qu'ils disent et font ce qu
il dit à propos de cette question
va-t-il s'arrêter au donbass vladimir
poutine l'a dit il l'a écrit l'ukraine
selon lui n'existe pas en quoi ce
pourrait-il se satisfaire entre
guillemets de n'avoir que encore entre
guillemets encore le donbass à faire
écouter à un moment ou un autre il a
quand même une opinion publique bon
c'est une dictature c'est devenu une
dictature à l'occasion de cette guerre
il ya plus de presse qui n'a pas le
droit de dire ce qu'elle pense
absolument d'ailleurs on le dit mais je
n'en avais pas le droit de dire que
c'est une guerre bon alors un moment il
faut qu'il dise qu'il a gagné quelque
chose pour comment il a perdu mais il
chose alors il peut dire voilà le
dombass était menacé le donbass était
bombardé tous les jours par l'armée
ukrainienne ces populations russophones
et russophiles était martyrisée par une
bande de nazis c'est le vocabulaire
qu'ils utilisent eh bien nous les avons
libérées
nous avons libéré mais ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on a une nouvelle ligne
de démarcation en europe entre la russie
et le reste de l'europe ça veut dire que
sur 600 ou 700 km on a l'équivalent de
ce qu'a été le mur de berlin dans les
années 1960 on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas d'ailleurs on a parlé tout à l'heure
il est question effectivement de faire
un témoin référendum dans la ville de
carson qui a été la seule grande ville
prise par les rues jusque ici pour la
rattacher éventuellement à la fédération
de russie en quoi alain frachon ce
conflit-là illustre cet autre monde qui
évoque le titre de votre ouvrage
à écouter il eu cet autre monde c'est un
autre monde que celui que nous avions
imaginé au moment de la chute du mur de
berlin et à la fin de la guerre froide
entre l'union soviétique et le bloc
occidental entre l'union soviétique et
les diesels y en avait imaginé un autre
monde que celui là et donc voilà on
avait imaginé que la démocratie libérale
l'économie de marché le libre-échange
tous allaient devenir des horizons
insurpassable et tout le monde allait y
aller gentiment et la rationalité
économique allait s'imposer eh bien pas
du tout c'est la passion de l'histoire
c'est la passion et biologiques qui
l'emportent et c'est cet autre monde
cette évolution vers cet autre monde que
celui dont le avions rêvé naïvement bien
c'est cette histoire là que je raconte
est ce aussi en ce qu'il consacre ce qu
on fait d'une certaine façon l
indéfectible amitié qui lie la russie de
vladimir poutine à la chine dossier jean
ping ce sont eux les les dictateurs du
titre
une amitié sans limite distille dans un
grand communiqué qu'ils ont écrit le 4
février dernier vladimir poutine va aux
jeux olympiques d'hiver en chine et puis
après il va rencontrer si jean ping et
ils font un grand communiqué d'une
douzaine de pages dit un texte étonnant
qu est une sorte de déclaration de
guerre politico culturel à l'occident
qu'on n'a pas assez lu non qu'on n'a pas
assez lu et ils disent une nouvelle ère
commence et c'est nous qui allons
assurer le leadership de la communauté
internationale c'est la fin du
leadership des occidentaux et on va
avoir une nouvelle architecture occident
une nouvelle architecture mondiale dans
laquelle
personne ne sera plus hostiles à
l'autocratie par principe dans laquelle
nous allons définir nous ce que sont les
libertés publiques et les droits de
l'homme et pas les autres par les autres
puisque cette architecture ne sera plus
placé sous l'influencé exclusive des
occidentaux comme c'est le cas depuis
1945 c'est un texte étonnant dans
laquelle ils utilisent eux-mêmes cette
expression nous entrons dans une
nouvelle ère et dans cette nouvelle ère
c'est nous qui allons donner la note
dominante front commun autocratique
autour duquel et pékin et moscou se
créer un réseau d'alliés un réseau
d'amis qui ne critiquent pas pour l'en
la guerre dans la guerre en ukraine où
la répression a démis moore pour l'autre
on a vu le résultat on a vu le résultat
lorsqu'il ya eu ces votes on n'a vu
qu'une partie du monde arabe et bien
refuser soit de condamner soin de
prendre des sanctions on n'a vu qu'une
partie de l'afrique c'était la même
chose
absolument à l'égard de la guerre en
ukraine et donc ils ont réussi déjà et
notamment la puissance de la diplomatie
chinoise mais aussi de la diplomatie
russe notamment en afrique au
moyen-orient diplomatie par ailleurs
très brillante dans ces pays là arrivent
à constituer soit des minorités de
blocage soit des majorités qui font que
il n'y a pas de condamnation pour les
ouigours il n'y a pas de condamnation
pour l'agression russe en ukraine
voilà c'est ça la nouvelle ère qui
s'annonce et c'est peut-être aussi ça la
ce qui va être le nouveau monde où les
batailles politiques ou idéologiques qui
vont avoir lieu dans le nouveau monde un
nouveau monde dans lequel demain la
chine sera peut-être pour la première
fois en tout cas de l'ère moderne la
première puissance mondiale vous allez
même plus loin alain frachon vous
écrivez que poutine et chine ont ceci en
commun de délégitimer la démocratie
libérale un mode de gouvernement dépassé
dit poutine qui sèment le chaos dichy la
caractéristique des régimes
autocratiques d'aujourd'hui et la
détestation de l'occident absolument il
ne le cache pas d'ailleurs dans ce
communiqué mais si je dis souvent sont
les idées occidentales nous sont
hostiles ils sont hostiles à
l'autocratie il faut donc les combattre
et nous on a oublié ce que c'était
qu'une bataille politico idéologique ou
politique ou culturelle eh bien on va
avoir à mener enfin cette bataille va
avoir lieu en tout cas cette bataille
doit avoir lieu elle a lieu déjà dans
toutes les organisations spécialisées
des nations unies si vous prenez une
organisation comme le conseil des droits
de l'homme de l'onu personne s'en
occupent nos autres journalistes on va
jamais voir ce qui s'y passe sa jeunesse
est pas loin pourtant et bien c'est là
qu'il ya eu une majorité de pays pour
refuser de condamner l'internement d'un
million de wii gour pourquoi pour ce
qu'ils sont pas pour ce qu'ils ont fait
voyez on est déjà dans cette bataille en
fait et l'occident de son côté alain
frachon queen de l'occident qui n'avait
pas besoin de ça l'occident a raté
écrivez-vous son entrée dans le 21e
siècle et récolte aujourd'hui le fruit
de ses erreurs pas tant donc parce
qu'ils seraient été écrasé par ce front
autocratique sino russes mais parce que
ils récoltent donc les ses erreurs et ne
peut que constater la déconsidération de
la démocratie occidentale voilà il ya
une forme de déconsidération de la
démocratie occidentale
on nous renvoie mais écoutez il ya deux
poids deux mesures vos indignations sont
à géométrie variable
parce que l'irak voilà parce que
l'afghanistan votre compétence en
économie mais écoutez d'abord regarder
il ya un autre modèle que le vôtre c'est
le modèle chinois qui va peut-être
devenir la première par le seul jeu des
effets de déchets n'a d'ailleurs
va devenir peut-être peut-être la
première puissance économique du monde
mais regardez votre compétence
économique mais après la crise de 2008
s'inquiète 2008 qui génère ensuite en
europe la crise des dettes souveraines
en a mis quatre cinq ou six ans à s'en
remettre des dizaines de millions de
gens ont perdu leurs logements aux états
unis où leur emploi en europe donc votre
compétence écoutez maintenant il ya un
autre modèle et voilà et voilà un peu ce
qui fait que on dit que l'occident a
raté son entrée dans ce qu'on appelle
cette première génération du 21e siècle
le premier 21e siècle mais il a raté
très largement par sa propre faute
dans quelle position est ce que ce ça
mais les états unis exercice délicat je
sais que résumer le monde en dix minutes
de bon matin les états unis pour qu'ils
écrivent et vous la politique chinoise
ou vantis chinoise est aussi droite que
l'obélisque du washington oui parce que
pour la première fois les états unis
affrontent un défi dans tous les
domaines ce qui n'était pas le cas
d'union du temps de l'union soviétique
le défi là il est économique il est
technologique il est militaire parce que
la chine est en train de devenir est
déjà une grande force militaire je vous
rappelle que la première marine de
guerre du monde maintenant c'est plus
les états unis c'est la chine avec je
crois 3 155 bâtiments de guerre mais
aussi culturel parce que la chine vend
son modèle si vous écoutez les discours
de sygic ping notamment au dernier
congrès du parti communiste chinois eh
bien ils proposent quasiment aux
africains le modèle chinois et comparer
dit il comparaît ce que nous avons
réussi à faire nous et les siècles qu'il
a fallu aux occidentaux pour être là où
ils sont et donc ça l'union soviétique
n'a jamais été un concurrent économique
même pas technologique un peu dans le
spatial ou un peu dont les industries
d'armement mais c'est tout et elle n'a
pas été un concurrent culturel personne
n'avait envie de ressembler à l'union
soviétique personne aucun pays du
tiers-monde n'avait envie de ressembler
à l'union soviétique et bien là on peut
faire on peut on peut comprendre qu'il
puisse qu'il puisse y avoir une
séduction du modèle chinois ici ou là
notamment l'afrique d'un mot allah
frachon on vous dit qu'on ne lit pas
assez des dictateurs on n'a pas lu petit
nid est-ce qu'on n'a pas assez lu et ce
qu'on ne lit pas à céchi notamment quand
il parle de taïwan
oui lorsqu'il parle de taiwan son
discours changent selon les moments il
maintient une pression militaire et en
même temps de temps en temps il dit mais
la solution sera pacifique absolument il
faut lire ce qu'ils disent parce que
d'abord ils peuvent mentir à des fins
cynique comme tous les hommes politiques
comme les nombres aussi mais ils sont
souvent convaincus de ce qu'ils disent
poutine était convaincu de ce qu'il
pensait et de ceux qui disaient sur
l'ukraine l'ukraine n'existe pas l'état
ukrainien n'existe pas il était
convaincu de cela dont l'erreur elle a
fait merci beaucoup merci infiniment
alain frachon est revenu ce matin sur ce
plateau